ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าขวดดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะก็มาเจอมาเจอกับเรา 2
คนหน้าใดวีดีโอบีกินเนอร์นะคะนายมี 5 สี
ฟ้าคะโอเควันคันนี้วันอะไร
วันนี้วันพฤหัสวันนี้วันพฤหัสเนาะวัน
พฤหัสบดีที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันพฤหัสที่ 16 ค่ะเดือนเดือนธันวาคมค่ะ
เดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเดือน
ธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่ 12 ค่ะปีพต
2564  a  Call ศ.
อีกหนึ่ง
แล้วเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
พุธ 5 วันพุธที่เท่าไหร่คะวันพุธที่ 15
เดือน
เดือนธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่
เท่าไหร่คะเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่ 12
ค่ะปีพตตปีพตต
2564 ปีคศ 2  02
1202 เหล็กเนาะให้มีวันอะไร
พรุ่งนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะวันศุกร์ที่เท่าไหร่
คะวันศุกร์ที่ 17 ค่ะเดือน
เดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็น
เดือนที่ติด 2 ค่ะปีพตต
เมื่อปีพตต
2564  a  Call ส
2  021
แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะพี่ฟ้าตอนนี้
เวลา
12:20 นค่ะหนูเที่ยง 20 นาที
เที่ยง 20 นาทีแล้ว
ครูฟ้ากินข้าวหรือยังเที่ยงแล้ว
ยังไม่ได้กินข้าวเลยค่ะ
หิวไหม
หนู
หิวนะหิวอ่ะหิวหนู
หิวผู้หญิงกินข้าวหรือยังคะยังไม่ได้กิน
เหมือนกันค่ะยังไม่ได้กิน
ดีเลยตาย
แล้วไม่หิวหรอ
คิว
หิวหนังเหมือนภูฟ้า
อะคิวก็เลยต้องทำอาหาร
ทำอาหาร
วันนี้เนี่ยกูหญิงเนี่ยคิดๆนะอยากจะกิน
ไข่เจียวไข่เจียว
นักเรียนเนี่ยรู้จักไข่เจียวไหม
นี่ค่ะดีเนาะไข่เจียว
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบไข่เจียวงูฟ้าชอบไข่เจียว
มากใช่วันนี้เนี่ยครูหญิงจะทำไข่เจียวค่ะ
ครูฟ้า
โอ้โหดีมากเลยค่ะคุณหญิงอายๆไปอยากกินไข่
เจียว
SM  EMS ไปให้มี
แต่ถ้าจะทำไข่เจียวเนี่ยนะคะก็ต้องมีไข่
โอ้โอ้โหไข่อันนี้เนี่ยเป็นไข่ไก่นะไก่
เนี่ยนะคะไข่ไก่หรอพี่ก็มีไข่ 1 ฟองไข่
หนึ่งฟอง 1 ฟองโอเคหรอโอเคแล้วอ่าแล้วก็
มีถ้วยนะหาถ้วยนะอ่า
ถ้วยหรอนายช่วยมีใครจะมี
น้ำมันเนาะน้ำมันพืชเห็นไหมครับน้ำมันพืช
มีน้ำมัน
มี
ก็วางข้างล่างนะคะเดี๋ยวล้มมีซีอิ๊วค่าซี
อิ๋วหมูอิอิอิทำจากถั่วเหลืองนาซีอิ๊วแต่
ว่าบางคนน่ะไม่ใส่สิ่งอิ้ว
ทำไมก็จะใส่น้ำปลา
น้ำปลา
จ่ายแต่ครูหญิงน่ะไม่ชอบไม่ชอบน้ำปลาชอบ
หิวใช่ก็เลยใส่ซีอิ๊วนี่ล่ะน้ำปลาน้ำปลา
มันมีกลิ่นนะคะ
เดี๋ยวเลยกินก็เค็มจะไม่มีเค็มเหมือนกัน
ซีอิ๊วเค็มน้ำปลาเค็มหรือว่าถ้าไม่ใส่
ซีอิ้วไม่ใส่น้ำปลา
ใช้อะไร
ดีอันนี้อ่ะ
อะไรคะคือฟ้าเออค่ะนอนแต่ขอ
เป็นเป็นผง
ซ้ายว่าผมไม่เจอเลยมีแต่ก้อนข้างนอกหงส์
ใส่ในไข่เจียวนะคะไปในไข่เจียว 5 แบบนี้
เอ้า
จะเป็นเป็นเป็นๆช้อนใช่ไหมตัดใส่
โอเคอ่ะหาวเองก็ยังชอบอันนี้ด้วยค่ะพริก
ไทย
พริกไทยบิ๊กไทยลีกไทยในเวลาสายให้
อาหารพริกไทยน้า
เขามีแล้วใส่ไข่เจียวใช่ไหมมีอะไรอีกไหม
คะค่ะเวลาทำไข่เจียวก็ต้องมีกระทะวันนี้
ดูกันนะไม่มีกถาเล็กมากกถาแล้วก็มีและก็
ต้องมี
ตะหลิวใช่ไหมคะตะหลิวคนฮะกระทะกับตะหลิว
อือ
กระทะอ่ะหนูมีอะอีกคะมีมีส้มมีส้มเอาไว้
ตีไข่เนาะลีไข่อาแล้วก็จริงๆเนี่ยถ้าทำ
ยังไงก็ต้องที
เอาจะไม่คัดเอามาเอาไว้แกงไก่เสี่ยวสัก as
ก็ได้น้องหมดแล้วนะของที่ต้องมี
ฮึนิดหน่อยนะนิดหน่อยเที่ยวใช้เวลานิด
หน่อยทำ
แล้วทำยังไงคะหนูเริ่มแรกใช่มั้ยก็ต้องมี
ถ้วยหรอแต่ก็กลิ่นก็จะมีไข่จะมันก็ต้อง
ตอกไข่ค่ะน้องต่อใครก็คือเอาไข่สมัยแล้ว
ก็ขอถ้าใครแข็งนะคะ
ออกให้เห็นใช่ไหมตอบไข่
ออกไข่ใส่ช้าม
เลือกไข่ไม่กินเหรอคะไม่กิน
ตามเนี่ยอุ้ยมองไม่เห็นอ้ะ
ต้องเห็นไหมอ่ะมองไม่เห็นไม่เห็นไม่เห็น
นะคะนักเรียนจริงๆสัตว์
มีขายก็ต้องตีไข่นะคะตีไข่ตีใคร
ดีไก่เพราะว่าใครเนี่ยมันจะมีไข่แดงใช่
ครูฟ้าน้องไข่แดงเป็นวงกลมแล้วก็ไข่ขาว
อะไรก็ต้องตีสีไข่
tdp
เพลงฮัก
ไม่ใช่ไข่แดงกับไข่ขาวเนี่ยมันเข้ากันก็
จะได้แบบนี้สีเหลืองๆตีไข่อ้าพ่อตีไข่
เสร็จแล้วนะคะก็ปรุงรสเนาะ
ปรุงรสใส่ซีอิ้วก็จะใส่ซีอิ๊ว
หิวคะถ้านักเรียนพบเค็มก็ใส่เยอะๆถ้า
เรียนไม่ชอบเค็มก็ใส่นิดหน่อยอันนี้นั่น
ใส่ตามชอบสิ่งนิ้วและผู้หญิงไม่ชอบกิน
ใส่ซีอิ๊ว
ผู้หญิงชอบคลิกใครใส่พริกไทยใส่ค่ะใส่พิษ
ไทยน็อคเปิดฝาแล้วก็โอเคแล้วค่ะพี่ชายแย่
จังเลย
แล้วก็สีที่ไม่ไหวตีไข่อีก 1 ครั้ง
ของเล่นตีไข่ไหมเกี่ยวใครตีใส่ไรอ่ะตีไข่
เนาะ
ให้มันเข้ากันนะคะก็เสร็จแล้ว
เสร็จแล้วหรอเนี่ยเสร็จแล้วต่อไปก็ถ้านัก
เรียนใช่ไหมคะมีเตา
สมัยแรงๆก็เอาเตามาตั้งมือก็ครับ
แล้วก็จุดไฟใช่ไหมอ่าเปิดเตาเนาะเปิดเตา
แล้วก็ตั้งกระทะอาหารตั้งกระทะเหมือน
เมื่อง่ายแล้วก็ร้องใช่ไหมรออ้ายกะๆร้อน
ร้อนเออแล้วทำยังไงต่อคะกระทะร้อนเนี่ย
กระทะร้อนแล้วก็ใส่น้ำมันค่ะอันนี้มัน
แล้วก็ใส่น้ำมัน
ใส่เยอะกไก่น้อยก็แตกแต่ใครเจอต้องใส่
เยอะหน่อยเนาะ
ใส่น้ำมัน
ก็ที่นี่ก็จะมีน้ำมัน
ก็เอาตะหลิวมาค่ะมาให้แล้วมันเนี่ยมัน
อยู่ทั่วกระทะนะคะช้าหมดเลยค่ะอ่ะๆแล้ว
นักเรียนบอกว่าไม่รู้กระทะ
ร้อนหรือไม่ร้อน
มันคนเพราะเอานิ้วแล้วก็แบบได้ไหมไม่ได้
ไม่ได้อ่ะอ่ามีแต่ว่ามันจะมีเอ่อมันมี
ควันนะคะสมมติกันใช่ไหม
เพราะว่าจะกลับๆค่ะเดี๋ยวกูฟ้าจะบอกว่าดู
ยังไงจะทักร้อนหรือยังไม่ร้อนอายุเป็นไฟ
ค่ะอ่ะ
ตั้งกระทะร้อนเนี่ยจะมีควันนั้นฟันหน้า
ขวัญนา 5 ฟันสายค่ะหน้าแบบนั้นเองไม่รู้
อีกวิธีนึงก็คือใช่ไหมเอานิดหน่อยแล้วก็
เอาไข่เนี่ยนิดหน่อยเนาะไข่เจียวนิดหน่อย
นะใส่ลงไปก่อนถ้ามันร้อนเราก็จะได้ยิน
เสียง
เออเราก็เอากระทะร้อนแล้วพอกระทะร้อนแล้ว
ก็
ใส่ไข่
นะคะลงไปค่ะถึงต้องเทใช่ไหมคะอยากเห็น
มั้ยเทไข่ลงไป
โอ้ยๆค่ะเชลงไปเนาะเราก็จะได้ยินเสียง
[เพลง]
เพราะว่า
เราก็รอใช่ไหมคะขอไข่เจียวเนี่ยมันคือการ
ขอโทษและมีน้ำมันเทไข่เนี่ยก็จะเป็นการ
ทอดไข่นะแต่กูยังไม่ได้ทอดนะคะนี้ทำให้ดู
เฉยๆอบนะคะทอดไข่ดีนะคะก็ๆแล้วก็กลับใช่
ไหมเมื่อกี้ก็ต้องรอต้องเช็คว่าไข่เคส
ตั้งโอเคก็ต่ำหน้าตาบอกเลยค่ะทอดใช่ไหม
นี้ผู้หญิงมีรูปให้ดูแล้วกันเนาะนักเรียน
เทไข่ลงไปทอดนี้มันก็จบฟูแบบนี้กูไม่เคย
เดียว
หูเที่ยวฟูมากอันนี้เขากระทะใหญ่มากดูสิ
กระทะแบบไทยอันนี้เป็นกระทะแบบถ่ายอะไร
อร่อยนะให้หัก grass
แล้วก็เหมือนครูฟ้าบอกแล้วก็ดูเพราะเห็น
ว่าสุกแล้วก็ทำอะไรนะคะคือฟ้ากลับ
ก็มีแต่เหอะกลับกลับกัน
จากตอนนี้ใช่ไหมคะข้างบนยังไม่สุกก็เอา
ตะหลิวตักแล้วก็กลับไข่กลับได้ไหม
แล้วเช็คยังไงอ่ะกูฟ้าว่าไข่เจียวเนี่ย
สุกแล้วกินได้แล้วเช็คก็เล็กไหมเทคนิคฟ้า
หรอคะเป็นสีเหลืองค่ะ
แบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะสีเหลืองสีเหลืองใช่ไหม
ดีเหลืองๆนะคะแล้วก็
ให้มันร้อนอ่ะแล้วห่อเป็นสีเหลืองเหลืองๆ
เนี่ยก็จะโอเคใช่ไหมกลับกลับกลับกลับกลับ
กลับนะมันเป็นสีเหลืองล็อคแบบนี้ใช่ไหม
ครูฟ้าสีเหลืองแบบนี้
แล้วก็เช็คแล้วก็ไข่เจียววันศุกร์แล้วก็
ตัดไข่เจียวสมัยเอาตะหลิวเนี่ยนะเอา
ตะหลิวเนี่ยตัดไข่เจียวใส่จานใส่จ้านต้อง
ไปสาดเห็นนะคะอาจารย์อันนี้คือจานเนาะตาก
ไข่เจียวใส่จานสมัยก็จะได้นี่เป็นสี
เหลืองๆสมัยแบบที่ครูฟ้าบอกอันนี้ถ้าไข่
เจียวเวลาดูแล้วสีเหลืองแบบนี้
โอเคสุกแล้วกินได้
ๆเอ่อก็กินไข่เจียวได้นะฮะแล้วก็ต้องมี
อาหารเข้า
ไปหากูฟ้าแบตพ่อชอบไข่เจียวใช่ไหมคะเออ
ครูฟ้านะกินไข่เจียวกับข้าวแล้วกินไข่
เจียวกับอะไรอีกไหมมีซอสมั้ยอ่ะล้อแม็
กกี้ค่ะ
ครูฟ้ากินกับซอสแม็กกี้สมัยตอนแคทเดียวๆ
วันนี้
กินอร่อยมาก
ค้าไม่กินไข่เจียวกับซอสศรีราชาเหรอคะ
ซอสพริกอ้ะโน้ตศรีราชาเป็นยังไงคะเนี่ย
ซอสพริกศรีราชา
ใช่ไหมแบบนี้แบบนี้เวลาดูขวดเป็นแบบนี้
แต่เวลาที่นักเรียน
เทสมัย a ใส่ถ้วย
ยังมันก็จะเป็นสีแดงๆ
พริกแล้วก็เวลากินก็เผ็ดเผ็ดนิดๆหน่อยๆ
ว่าบางคนเนี่ยกินไข่เจียวกับซอสพริก
ศรีราชาแตกฟ้าไม่กินไม่กินกับซอสพริกค่ะ
มือซอสพริกนึงว่ากินไข่เจียวกับแม็กกี้
โอเคใช่ไหมไม่เป็นไรโอเคอ่ะไม่เป็นไรถ้า
นักเรียนเนี่ยบอกว่าไม่ชอบ
ซอสพริกไม่ชอบแม็กกี้กินไข่เจียวอย่าง
เดียวโอเคไหมคะถ้านักเรียนไม่ชอบซอสพริก
ไม่ชอบแม็กกี้ไข่เจียวอย่างเดียวโอเคค่ะ
ใช่มั้ยไม่ไม่ต้องมีซอสโซได้ไม่ต้องมีซอย
เสื้อร้อนจะได้ให้ผู้พาก็กินแบบไม่มีซอส
ส้มเอง
ๆไม่ค่อยใส่ซอสค่ะหน้าแต่ขลุ่ยแม่กินที
เดียวกับซอสพริก 2 รอบไข่เดียวกับซอสพริก
ราก็จะใส่ซอสพริกจับนึงไม่เคยกินไข่เชียว
กับแบ็กกี้ส์ปิ๊กกี้เลยไข่เจียวแล้วก็
แม็กซ์กี้เนี่ย
ไม่เคยกินไม่เคยเห็นไม่เคยกิน
นี่ไงมากินกับใคร
ใช่กินกับไข่ดาวกูยังไม่เคยกินเมื่อกี้
คู่กับไข่เจียวไม่เคยเท่าไหร่มาก
นักเรียนนักเรียนเนี่ยเคยกินไข่เจียวไหม
ไม่รู้นักเรียนเนี่ยเคยกินไหมไข่เดียวนะ
คะห๊า
ถ้านักเรียนเนี่ยครูฟ้าผู้หญิงแหละกิน
สมัยเคยกินไข่เจียวครูฟ้าก็ทำใช่ไหมคะทำ
ไข่เจียวได้โอเคได้อ้ะได้
อร่อยอร่อยดี 5
กินไข่เจียวมาก็ทำเดียวได้ถึงสมัยนัก
เรียนเนี่ยกินไข่เจียวไหม
ไหมแล้วนักเรียนเนี่ยกินไข่เจียวกับ
อะไหล่เออขี้ซอสพริกซอสมะเขือเทศ
ซอสมะเขือเทศ
Piece
ไม่รู้อะไรก็ได้ใช่ไหมใส่แล้วนักเรียนอาจ
จะมีออมเล็ตมาที่มันเป็นหินอ่าสาวๆไป
เที่ยวจะเป็นใหญ่ๆแล้วก็คนไทยต้องใส่ซอส
อะไรต้องใส่ซีอิ๊วใส่น้ำปลาแล้วแบบมี
อร่อยอ่ะไม่ต้องเป็นแบบไข่เจียวแบบคนไทย
ใครเดียวแบบไทย
นักเรียนผม
ผมมากๆๆ
ใช่น้องก็ให้อร่อยจ่ายนักเรียนไม่รู้นัก
เรียนดูวีดีโอนี้แล้วนักเรียนทำไข่เจียว
เลาะลองทำแล้วก็คอมเม้นท์บอกได้ว่าเป็น
ยังไงนะโอเคให้โอเคผู้หญิงนิติไม่โอเคใคร
6 โลเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงต้องไปเก็บก่อนนั้น
เก็บก่อนนะคะแล้วเดี๋ยวเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอ
หน้าเนาะอ่ะ